Frankie here at Kapow comic convention
today what have you been doing here I've
been to avoid people largely pure yeah
I'm here yesterday and it was like
bizarre mics are [ __ ] not really at
all famous but I guess I've got big red
beard so people can recognize me so it's
just like [ __ ] zombie movie if people
who perhaps don't even do it late you
coming out feel shocked sorry I went for
a nap at the end of it and there I felt
a lot better do i it seems really me
isn't it amazing their venue for it's
nice and airy and not gonna you know not
connect at all and there's so many
people here it's good and you did a
panel today haven't you as well and it
was supposed to be always down for 45
minutes and end up being an hour and 15
to a packed room I mean we just kept
[ __ ] talking because we didn't know
how long we were supposed to do that was
what happened there and yeah there's a
lot of confused rambling from me about
him
what I told him it I said largely and I
enjoyed it I don't know what they took
away from it hopefully they latched on
to the few sentences that made sense and
and their little key name now Lou you
know you love your comics don't you I
mean how did you get into them in the
first place and different ways I mean I
read kind of all British comics and I
read like you know the ones you would
have as a kid devack done all that stuff
but old I did read American comics was a
lot okay there wasn't until my like the
Silver Surfer and I sort of have my mind
blown by this comment when I was a kid
it was like I think it's a giant code
big comet with metro and but as a little
kid like five or six si saying it's like
[ __ ] metal and comes up to those less
like galactic [ __ ] present for
supervillains with it all tied to
asteroids if he was in this it all they
came giant giant versions of whoever's
in present in the asteroid present thing
are so strapped in agony like Promethean
can have agony to these rocks and that
thing is there present Hank and they can
it's of scare pay of it and stuff and as
I cared not even really knowing that the
earth was round like you know looking
that's just
absolutely absolutely mental yes I've
always had a think one so as you've gone
through the years and grown up though
what are the ones that particularly have
kept you no place in your heart you know
what it's all of them I mean I would eat
anything and I'll take for that eyes
good over that's something about images
and words together that I really love
and so like I mean I had my kids like I
read the comics and then I read them to
my kids that can be edited versions
those two edited versions one for their
kids and one for the locket and then I
hid them at all annihilation conquest
thing recently generalized so it's like
that [ __ ] there what she called
rocket racoon and they're the greatest
ape man and all that stuff and on some
levels that's not a very good comic you
know but on a lot of levels it's kid
agree it is well that [ __ ] record is
firing about space and just part of some
mayor and you know intergalactic [ __ ]
chaos a defeating agency and yeah I
really enjoyed that pretty much whatever
I've just read I've really enjoyed and
at same time you do recognize sometimes
as you know things are there a lot of
things are very good but there's also
like a things how are you kids
responding to the comics are they loving
them like you did as a kid my boy really
love the comics he's for EM but my
daughter Leigh I saw that she's not
enough good female characters in comics
you see finger what we go was getting
commentor Fantastic Four and you know
you've got two female characters in it
caring but there's just not enough
comics a for girls and the ones that
there are honor just to be but you know
Supergirl whoever that's just a bad
[ __ ] stereotyped and that's a bit of
a meal view of of what ghetto superhero
would be in you know the real Sheila's a
real gap there for someone it is strong
female characters a more just more
interests and varied stories with female
characters it's very hard to find stuff
for do you think it's not something age
maybe think of doing and writing stories
for her no I don't you know you should
have female rails dinner really I mean
it's just that thing of I said in every
industry isn't it you know
is there all to male-dominated and
comedy as well you know I mean people
talk about why is it difficult for
female comedians well one of the reasons
is it male comedians of [ __ ] [ __ ] to
them so I mean it's pretty hard to be a
female comedian and travel around a
different dressing room every weekend
kiss you know we the slight been in you
know football teams locker rooms you
know I mean it's not that's not actually
that encouraging
you